i got to play this for you this is a
presbyterian church in iowa um
female pastor
no coincidence there giving her version
of a prayer
and uh just listen to this
oh god of pronouns
we give praise to the great one
the one who was identifiable as god
i am what i am you say
the great they
the incarnate he and she
the god of trans being
impregnating mary
fathering god
breastfeeding god of many breasts
you shadow you shatter all stereotypes
making every single person
male
and female
male and female
intersex
non-binary in your image
exactly in your image
spectrum
rainbow god who put your promise for
non-violence in the symbol for queer
love
before humanity knew
because you knew
who had joseph who could not sleep with
a woman in a beautiful lady's cloak
perhaps of rainbow colors
before we knew
you knew
god of pronouns who said you can call me
he or she or they
whatever makes you feel closest to me
the great they
that's how she refers to god
uh the god of pronouns now
first of all it's not a it's actually
not a coincidence that the um that this
is a female pastor
saying all this not to suggest that
the bad pastors are always female
there's a lot of there's a lot of
a lot of a lot of bad men leading
churches as well in this country and
across the west and across the world
but it's also not a coincidence that the
craziest and most heretical stuff
usually happens at churches with female
pastors that is not a coincidence and
the reason it's not a coincidence is
that churches
which that have already bought into
feminism
were destined to continue the slide into
what we're seeing now that's the
connection there
and what we see there is
um what we've seen in in many churches
again across the west just this is a
this is a very
uh
one one of the more shocking examples of
it but
this is god
made in the image of
man
rather than man made in the image of god
that's the way she
she in this church
she is trying to remake god in her own
image
in the image of what she thinks humanity
is
it's a it's a complete inversion
of the actual message of the bible
how the bible begins
male and female he created them and she
even says that there's there's one talk
about shocking there's one surprising
moment where she says you made them male
and female and you stopped and said hold
on a second you're admitting that much
at least then she continues and intersex
and non-binary
no actually um that's
not in the scripture at all in fact it
says that male and female he created
them there are no other categories
provided
and that's not just in the beginning of
the bible it's all throughout the bible
there are many exhortations
given to men and to women and there's
never a third there's never a time where
oh yeah and the third category over here
here's what you should do
so we see her in real time rewriting the
bible
and trying to rewrite god remake god in
her own twisted self-image
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends